Marcus Peters being suspended by his
team the Chiefs for conduct detrimental
Peter King joining us here on the show
how are you Peter everything's good
we're it's you I'm hanging in there
thank you um so what do you make of the
Chiefs news that a team at once upon a
time five I know having lost six is
seven big game against the Raiders who
could wind up sweep in a series from
them this year
sit Marcus Peters themselves I applaud
Andy Reed you know basically I think one
of the problems is that the Chiefs in
losing six out of seven which have not
only not played great they've lost their
poise several times including very very
badly at the end of the game against the
Jets you know it isn't just the defense
fell apart and gave up 38 points to Josh
but Josh McCown it's that they melted
down in the process and so Andy Reid is
saying I don't care how valuable you are
to this team you're probably our best
defensive player but you're not playing
until you learn how to channel your
emotion I think Andy Reid needs to get a
hold of his team at Lots there they lost
their poise in this game against the
Jets and I applaud his move
no matter how valuable Marcus Peters is
to his team all right now what do you
think of Iloka having his penalty his
suspension overturned by Derrick Brooks
as long as you juice miss user doesn't
have his overturned I'm okay with it I
mean Minoo Iloka that was a that was a
brutal hit it was a terrible hit but to
me the Smith Shuster thing is is worse
because it's worse for the game to be
standing over a guiding him while you
know while the a teammate of yours yep
is in the hospital you have no idea if
he's ever going to walk again I just
think was the height of idiocy
and I loco was a football play that was
way way over the top but you know if
that gets overturned I kind of under
stand it but I would not understand if
Smith Shuster got overturn well I mean I
don't know I mean the Iloka one was so
nasty and at the end of a nasty game
where you could say the same thing is
that somebody got carted off earlier in
the day and it's not just a teammate
it's it's a it's a brother in in
football arms here for him to go top
rope on Antonia Brown like that and
crush his head with his helmet that I
don't know it just seems to me that
maybe everybody's suspension should have
been upheld Peter I would not have
minded if I loco was suspended rich I I
think it would have been justifiable and
obviously that Jon Runyan and the league
thought that it was I guess my whole
point is that there are plays like that
I'm not saying in every game but their
plays similar to that most weekends in
the NFL and you know again a suspension
I think I
and again that's a borderline one Iloka
a you know a suspension and I'm ok with
it because of what the NFL was trying to
emphasize now but my my my hesitancy is
that I don't want suspensions I mean it
to be to become really really
commonplace because I think it is really
serious you know and normally I mean you
know the NFL suspended three people in
one weekend you know and it used to be
the NFL would give out heavy fines and I
think what the NFL is basically saying
now is that the fines don't work and
they don't they don't work and and
Gronkowski certainly deserved that if he
given more than one game and upset but
you know the Iloka thing I think if you
suspend that play I'm saying that you
could probably find a play in 17
weekends of NFL football at like every
weekend where you'd suspend somebody
that's why I think it's slippery slope
and then I guess the last one on this
subject is that you know how could
Gronkowski what he did be equated to
what juju Smith Shuster did
and and the the the fine system and the
and the penalty in the in the suspension
system are the Lee gotta moves here
though Peter in terms of trying to
prevent these things from happening I
mean they don't know I don't I I support
you know suspensions particularly in
egregious things play Gronkowski and
Smyth Shuster to me absolutely certainly
deserved it I think in both cases
because I think we've gotten to the
point now rich where it's been proven
time and again you look at the Bengals
and the Steelers there is no deterrent
factor when you find somebody that
totally out of line and I mean I'm I you
know what I'd do if I were Roger Goodell
okay so they're done for this year to
bangles viewers if I were Roger Goodell
you know he usually goes to the Scouting
Combine obviously he sees them at the
league meeting I would get Mike Tomlin
and and Marvin Lewis and I would just
say the I don't like what in the games
between your teams and we've tried fines
we've tried suspensions the next thing
that we're going is going to suspend a
coach if this stuff continues that's how
I would handle it I don't I do not
accept the Ben Roethlisberger this is
AFC North ball that's yeah you know if
we justify the kind of behavior we saw
Monday night as well hey that's just an
assay FC North football in the AFC North
oughta secede from the union Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show question is
is Marvin Lewis going to be around to
have that conversation you know that's a
you know Mike Brown is very comfortable
with Marvin Lewis because he handles all
the problem children that he puts in his
locker room and you know that's the way
they like to operate I I mean look if
Marvin Lewis hasn't been fired right now
I don't know what he's going to do this
year it's kind of akin
fireable I'm not saying he won't be
right but you know they ever won a
playoff game in a hundred years and the
guy keeps coaching so I you know maybe
it'll be gone but I I don't I don't
really think he will be because Mike
Brown has a comfort with Marvin Lewis
so who's coaching for their jobs in the
final four weeks you think Peter Chuck
Pagano John Fox for sure I can't see
Pagano coming back I think it's probably
unlikely the clocks comes back
I don't know I'm probably being a great
thing Jason it's going to return unless
Jerry Jones falls in love with somebody
like Jon Gruden in the next month or so
and I you know again I think there would
be a couple of interesting places to
watch okay look at Tampa Bay take Greg
Schiano
2012-2013 2 years fired
lovie smith 2014-2015 fired dirk cutter
2016-2017 underachieving
dare the tampa bay buccaneers again get
rid of a coach after 2 years are they
going to be a big mistake but you got to
watch that just based on history I think
you also have to watch the Detroit Lions
I mean how are the Detroit Lions one
game under 500 since Opening Day 2015
rich explained that III mean every year
I hear that oh my god Matthew Stafford
top five quarterback finally they fix
defense it done this it's a same broken
record story every year with the Detroit
Lions
so at some point is Jim Caldwell going
to be called on the carpet for that
we'll see I think Jay Gruden is back in
Washington most likely you got to watch
Bruce Arians either by his choice it
sounds like he definitely wants to
return for one more year
I don't see any changes being made in
the AFC and I don't know I think that's
about it for now I think the the AFC
West is probably safe even though I
think Vance Joe
people saying what the heck happened
there I I'd be surprised if John Elway
pulled the trigger after one year so
last one for you read the tea leaves for
me on on the Giants job who do you think
is gonna go wind up with that well
they're gonna pick a general manager
first I mean look the logic says Ernie
Accorsi you know who's helping John
Mayer on this right absolutely loves and
admires Dave gentlemen Dave gentleman's
on the street they could hire him
tomorrow and so I mean I if you're
asking me a leader in the clubhouse I
think both gentlemen and and John Dorsey
are very interesting candidates because
the Giants would have a comfort zone
with people who they they know and be
they have great respect for their people
in the Giants organization with great
respect for John Dorsey the football man
so if one of those two guys gets it that
gets a Giants a head start and I'm not
saying that's going to happen I think
John Mayer is absolutely wide open on
what he would do and then as far as a
coach I think you round up the usual
suspects would not be surprised if they
were aggressive on josh mcdaniels but
again i I just think it's way too early
to know because they don't know that the
general manager is going to be mm-hmm
and I've been pounding the table for
David Shaw III think he's a man well I
did rich I you know I would I'd hire
David Choe yesterday there's no question
about it but I go back to I've talked to
David Shaw about this twice in the last
two years and he had a great line he
said I love where I am I have a better
job than any coach in the NFL number one
and number two
anything wants to get me out of here the
first thing they're gonna have to do is
convince my that their city is better
than palo alto and he goes that's gonna
be hard I guess the last one for you
anything on shazier a hearing anything
on Ryan as weird you're you're on the
train and I'm sitting out here
am i hearing anything on what written
Ryan shazier I know I have not heard it
I have not heard a thing and I'm
concerned obviously everybody would be
concerned but I'm sorry to say I'm not
all right Peter thanks for calling in I
appreciate it well chat soon
okay we're always appreciated add SI
underscore Peter King the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience